there's actually water in here oh yeah
yeah there's water it's nice yeah that's
good
oh yeah it's a tv show you're just happy
to be anywhere right now huh
what happened to your hair because on uh
third rock from the sun you got that
hippie sort of kid thing going
are you calling me a hippie what are you
inferring what is that all right yeah
hippie isn't an insult oh okay
long-haired hippie is an insult but uh
you're just a friendly hippie all right
um i cut my hair i had had it long for a
long time and i've been asking them
uh hey can i cut my hair soon because
it's hot when you sleep and it's summer
and
i'd like to cut my hair did you have to
ask there's lots of people there's
there's all sorts of people that are
like
yes there are many people there's lots
of people ask are any of them invisible
yeah why yes
yes they are uh they say we like your
hair uh
it's distinct it's good there's not kids
with long hair on television so keep
your hair long and i was like i don't
want to but eventually they let me
that's weird cause people don't think
about that but when you're on tv like
andy and i if we wanted to grow weird
sort of van dyke beard
we couldn't because it would freak
everybody out at home and they would see
you know some guy in a suit would show
up and say testing shows that your
facial hair is freakish you know
if i wanted to grow a van dyke beard i
couldn't either but that's just because
i'm young and i can't grow beards either
too
well i was just trying to fake it uh i'd
need an operation
i should grow a big beard that's
horrible sorry that didn't happen
edit that part out uh listen uh this
movie halloween h2o
okay first of all the title really
confuses me but we won't get into that
because it doesn't take place in water
no no there's a there's no water it's
it's the 20th anniversary
and halloween begins with the letter h
it's right
but it still is confusing because then
the isn't the tagline blood is thicker
than water or something oh is it
yeah uh i mean i knew that
yeah yeah i just think people are going
to go and think it's going to be cool
you know mike myers is underwater fight
scenes
right right pow biff yeah change that
title now uh
do you like halloween do you enjoy
halloween i do yeah i like halloween
i used to get really into it when i was
young uh i built a graveyard in my
friend's front yard and we'd uh
we'd put on masks and pretend that we
were dummies we'd put like newspaper in
our sleeves and
lay down and then people would come up
and say oh look a dummy and we go
and we thought we were really scary and
funny but i think most people went
look at these kids also also what kind
of low rent graveyard just lays the
bodies down on top
you know you're supposed to get under
some soil and go
but you're just like i'm a dead guy yeah
did you uh did you have elaborate
costumes and everything yeah i don't
know
we were ten you know it was fun okay
blood's fun when you're ten fake blood
yeah sure
do you like scary movies uh are you one
of those people that really enjoys them
i like i like any movie i like good
movies like uh anything i'm gonna
disagree with you there
i enjoy a movie that's poorly made which
has no point and has poor production
values
i don't like those movies generally i
like good movies you like yeah any movie
that's good you know uh
psycho is a really good scary movie the
shining right uh
but you know i don't like a movie just
for the sake of being scary this movie
is a good movie
this this halloween movie it's um it
sets out to do what it's gonna do and it
does it it's 90 minutes long
it's scary it's what it is and it's good
and it's like
it's what it is it's good you know it's
halloween h2o
that's what it is it's what it is
because the thing is
there are lots of scary movies and
they'll try to make them meaningful or
they'll try to put
different um emotional stuff in there i
hate emotion i hate emotion
i'm half vulcan it's a bunch of crap
here so
this is just it's uh you know it's scary
okay it sounds good and it's it's got
history it's like a cult movie i went to
a sneak preview
of it and uh everyone in it you know was
a fan of the original movie and they're
all
talking back and yelling it's kind of
got a rocky horror thing going
in that way it's it's a very fun thing
you probably weren't when the first
halloween came out you probably weren't
even alive
no wonder it came out in like uh 75 or
something
that no i wasn't alive well that would
be 20 years
see you should have kept that you hurt
me terribly i'm sorry but
it had to be done h2o h2o i just think
that's water i'm not buying the 20 years
thing
i'm not that's that bad yeah that
illustrates the problem with the title i
just think
all right when's the water scene coming
up there's no water scene 20 years
i think it's cool that it's underwater
this movie uh
that's gonna be my favorite part if it's
not there i'll be disappointed
um but uh
i just before we go i have to do this
your name gordon levitt
it's like how did you get that is that
your middle name and your last name
my mom's last name is gordon and my
dad's last name is levitt
and my parents actually were hippies and
so
well they were i was right you are a
hippie well now my father drives a bmw
he's not a hippie anymore but they used
to be hippies and so they figured you
know uh
why why should a woman uh lose her name
why should
so uh so i have two last things
so few people got behind that idea
but also and also with that kind of
thinking in in like two or three
generations people
have names that are eight like i'm
worried about that actually if i meet a
girl with
two names then my kid will have four
names i think the person with the better
name
should have you know the better last
name should win the better one seriously
but then you'll get into arguments if
like a guy whose last name is like you
know
henderson marries a person whose name is
like schlabble-gabba-goo
i think schlabel gavagu should win cause
that's a cool name
i hope i've made my point
well uh halloween uh
third rock yadda yadda oh sorry
go ahead guys i was trying to do you a
favor and plug the movie
well i guess we won't do that now no the
the movie uh is in theaters now and of
course murdoch from the sun is on
wednesday nights
on uh wednesday nights on nbc right yes
it is
it actually is in fact well our
questioning's over you can go now son
can i take it yes sir yeah you can take
the cup too but thanks very much for
coming on the program uh best of luck
joseph gordon everybody patrice o'neal
coming up